you know we've talked about are we are
we the collapse are we the fall of the
Roman Republic or the Empire Republic
that means we're entering the Empire
period which is 200 years of prosperity
under autocracy no I've warned several
times that a Franco is coming we have a
Francisco Franco coming he is coming
people Trump no no no no see the thing
about system disruptors and I know you
guys know this but the Roman Republic
people will know their own Republic and
that eventually Caesar takes over he's
killed but then from then on they were
led by Emperors that was the Roman
Empire but Caesar everyone knows Caesar
what they don't know is there were
several they were called populares the
populists really there were several
populares before Caesar the grocky
brothers and all these others they would
rise and then they'd kill them and then
they would rise and then system would
kill him and rise in the system would
kill him and what happened in the end
was you got somebody who's honestly
probably the most intelligent or one of
the most intelligent capable people who
ever lived Caesar would rise your first
system disruptor like Trump gets credit
for having the balls to be the first to
challenge it but he's also the dumbest
why because he doesn't know how corrupt
it is yet I didn't know how corrupt it
was yet when Trump joined the next one
gets smarter that's a good thing the bad
thing is the next one will be meaner
they get smarter and meaner and then
they're smarter and meaner and then
they're smarter and meaner and soon you
have one who's smart and capable enough
which is good but then he's also mean
enough that's where we'll go we will go
there that won't be tomorrow this is
years in the making but they'll get
smarter and meaner as we go along I feel
the government's already pretty mean if
that's why that's why the system
disruptor gets smarter and meaner though
because they they learn from the last
guy's mistakes I can't do this I have to
make sure I smash them I have to make
sure I do this smarter and meaner
smarter and meaner and then sooner or
later people are getting their
fingernails pulled out and you look
around and say how do we end up with
this country well that's how we're
getting these cultural people that
appear that are trying to change the
culture and the system's inoculating
itself against cultural change by taking
control of the culture through mass
media they're trying to I keep thinking
how do we fix the culture on Earth and
what I realized is I'm not going for a
cultural Victory I'm going for a
religious Victory I'm done with culture
man I'm done trying to trick people and
make them smile you need to look at God
this is real the world is unifying Islam
Christianity and Judaism they're coming
together under one God that's the point
and we need
that that's my new methodology is is a
religious victory
do you want some of this brother alcohol
does not treat me well I'm not maybe
it's exactly what you need right now so
someone in the Super Chat said FDR was
the first emperor and so we've been in
the Empire what do you think do you
agree I don't know no no we haven't been
but we are I'm noticing more and more as
time goes along that we have this
illusion that we can change the
government especially when it comes to
the federal government we very clearly
are not in a place where we can change
the federal government people we're all
we're almost universally we have this
representative Republic but almost
universally people are displeased with
the federal government how does that
make sense if we're choosing these
people but we're all displeased with
these people then what's actually going
on there well what's going on there is
we're run by an administrative State
Congress doesn't run anything did
Christopher Ray went and sat in front of
Chuck Grassley is the top GOP guy in the
Senate Judiciary Committee that's maybe
the most powerful Committee in all of
Washington Grassley was the top guy
Grassley says hey are you going to
answer some questions and Christopher
Ray says sorry I got a plane to catch
it's my own private plane but peace out
see you Chuck now what that told me
everyone was mad at Grassley and her mad
at Christopher Ray what it told me was
Christopher Ray he's not concerned in
the least about Congress we're already
hearing about we're gonna have hearings
and they're going to be subpoenas the
FBI was hearing that they were going to
be subpoenas early on and you know what
their response to that was they didn't
moderate they didn't back off they went
and arrested a pastor who read Bible
verses at an abortion clinic out there
they ramped it up they're not even the
administrative state is not even that
scared of the Republican party and that
is the problem until the administrative
State fears Republicans will never have
anything it sounds like an Empire to me
but uh I I think that's that's a that's
an interesting discussion there
especially with FDR because after FDR
after World War II the United States did
start expanding its Empire and setting
up military bases all over the world to
where we are now where the United States
nearly spends more on its military than
almost the whole entire world not
exactly the stats are contested
especially because of the secret black
budgets especially because of what China
is also doing behind the scenes but at
the same time I think it's worth kind of
considering that yeah maybe there was an
Empire after FDR and uh especially when
it comes to the president's only being
figureheads and the agenda and the
foreign policy and the major directions
that this country has been headed in has
always been kind of consistent and no
matter if it's a Democrat or Republican
a lot of the bigger policies don't
usually change it's the British Empire
man they after World War one they set up
Israel they built it with the British
mandate for Palestine they want military
bases in the Middle East to protect the
Suez Canal that's the Empire that we
live under and that Empire is about to
change and become a new world Empire so
our words are guiding it yeah Brix is
another Empire but is that what replaces
us it's either they're going to either
amalgamate and one of them is going to
become the new one as a larger grander
scheme or they're all going to fall away
and a new one's going to erupt but it's
likely that one of the current the
current ones will evolve together and
kind of create okay pockets of a new
sort of global Empire it's going to be
fiscal they're trying to make people get
tattoos and follow them around with
their phones and crap
you think bricks you know one theory is
that uh the US Patriot dollar starts to
crumble and then bricks takes over and
then it's a Chinese Communist unipolar
world I I actually see I've been kind of
a dead now I'm going to be the hopeful
one I've been kind of cynical I I am a
little bit more hopeful on this now I
agree basically with what you're saying
that there's we're going into a fourth
turning that there's going to be a
gigantic gigantic world changing events
the Wars famines all of these things are
always inevitable they're always coming
back around and we're going to cast off
the old systems and we're going to
choose new systems but I will say that
there is something that that really
should give people a bit of hope that
that we have guns lots and lots of guns
in red America lots and lots of state
power also we have these hugely powerful
states that we still have a powerful
State system now it's not as powerful as
it should be but there are all these
states that can and will join together
and you have armed citizens there so
even if every disarmed British citizen a
German citizen or or or Dutch citizen
who see what those poor farmers are
going through right now even if
everything else starts to go to crap and
crumble around us there is still one
there's tens of millions of tens of
millions of Americans who think like you
think and there is safety in these areas
some amount of safety still in these
areas I I believe there's a lot still to
preserve even if the federal system is
all but lost I believe there's tons
still to preserve in this country
yeah
yeah I think the American statehood is a
good example of how to lead the world if
we could have lots of decentralized
states of communities well that's how
America was supposed to be now slowly
but surely over time states were seeding
more and more power to the federal
government and we look look where we are
now we see how that where that's gotten
us but there's still a tremendous amount
of infrastructure in place at our state
level that even other countries like
Canada the provinces don't have that we
do here Texas has its own power grid
like we have we have things here we have
we have huge pockets of this country
that we that where people can live free
where your kids and grandkids can live
free and live live a life that's very
similar to the life you live is the
federal government salvageable no
probably not they suck flush it down the
toilet but there's still a bunch of the
country that is and that's good yeah
America still is one of the freest
places in the world I mean traveling the
world you don't have a lot of places
where you could you know Express
whatever you want to express and also at
the same time be able to defend yourself
now uh in and you compare it to what's
happening in China you could see why a
lot of the top controllers why a lot of
the big politicians want a society like
China because it's easier to manage
because there's less freedoms there's
less people being able to defend
themselves this is the larger battle
that I think is unfolding right now with
a lot of people working and progressing
towards creating a Chinese style Society
here in the United States and I think
this is the bigger fight that people
need to realize and this is a fight not
between the Republicans and the
Democrats this is the Republicans
Democrats working together to screw
everyone else over that's how I just see
it if you want to know if the Chinese
style of government is going to be good
here look uh no further than the Chinese
people because they'll tell you and
they're revolting against their
government right now and I've seen tanks
the government has sent out tanks
against these people I don't know if the
videos are real but that's what it looks
like is happening what do you think we
can do Jesse to help these people to
help the people of China nothing because
our own government's against us too we
don't have an Avenue we can't look you
can't hop in your bass boat and cross
the Pacific and go invade mainly in
China what can we do well I shouldn't
say nothing that's not true the power of
prayer is real we can pray for him but
other than that nothing now that we have
our own broken government we are sadly
in a place where people are going to
have to wake up and realize that the
days of you know bouncing around the
globe and being a for the forces of good
if you ever really kind of subscribe to
that sort of thing that's going to have
to go away because we have real problems
here at home all the leaders of the
western Nations I say this all the time
on my show they all share the same
characteristics now the same three all
of them and that's not just America you
know it's Germany Britain all of them
they all no love of country many of them
hate their country you know the leaders
of our institutions from the presidents
to our entertainers to our athletes many
of them hate the country but even if
they don't there's no love of country if
you wake up you probably do you wake up
every single morning and something will
occur to you and you'll think man that's
bad for America or man I wish we would
do this because that's good for America
those thoughts never enter the minds of
the leaders of the western Nations now
two they don't have any connection to
the real world how normal people live
somebody right now is watching Tim cast
and just got off of his second shift of
the day and he's sitting down and just
wants to watch it catch up on things and
the people who run our society have no
idea what that guy goes through and
three they see themselves as kings and
queens the leaders of the West used to
look at themselves as the knights who
would guard the freedoms of the West now
they look at the freedoms of the West
and they're disgusted by them they think
the problem with the West is your
freedom you can look what we're talking
about all night tonight with Twitter the
problem is you can say whatever you want
what that's ridiculous peasant you can
own a gun oh that's horrible I as the
king should be able to tell you where to
go what to eat where to drive what you
can say and what you can say that's the
problem there's two ways to look at it
that at a certain point we lulled
ourselves through our comfort into
letting these people take control of the
machine or we can say that over time
these people started to gain control of
the machine
you you have like like you mentioned
they used to be the knights defending
freedom and standing up for us I mean
those are the founding fathers the
battles they fought now it's the
parasitic manipulators who are leeching
off the system and I guess the question
then becomes is it because we were
apathetic and let uh ignorant uh what's
the saying the penalty for not being
involved in politics is that your
lessers will rule over you or is it that
evil people manipulated the system to to
take control from us without us
realizing it was because we were we were
apathetic evil people have always
existed they existed 3000 years ago a
thousand years ago 50 years ago evil
people have always been there we got
look take hard in this if some of this
is bumming you out this was always
inevitable this is what happens to
wealthy absurd Nations we got absurdly
wealthy in this country with a
ridiculous standard of living that most
parts of the world would never even
recognize and that kind of wealth makes
you fat and bored and apathetic and you
just stop paying it tension I'm sorry
were you saying something to him I can
look up a YouTube video on brain surgery
right now if I could do whatever I want
here on my phone I don't oh what you're
talking about the greatest phone case
but is that your passport photo for
those that didn't see he's got his own
face on his iPhone
but look we got apathetic but don't beat
yourself up over that if you're an
American it's human nature to get
apathetic when you get rich when you get
rich you just kind of stop it happened
to the Mongols the Mongols were this
tiny little tribe in Mongolia eating
eating mouse guts and soon you kicked
everyone's rear end now you're living in
Chinese silks in a Chinese Mansion
there's about one more generation right
back to Mongolia with you yeah
it really messed it up he was a drunk
and that that's the downfall of that
Civilization it takes Generations but it
I think it happened here too we had the
brave men 200 years ago that were
willing to die to protect this well not
even that less than 100 years ago Ted
Williams Ted Williams quit playing
professional baseball to go fight Nazis
tell me the professional athlete Pat
Tillman rest his soul aside that would
they would do that no they're all busy
crapping on the place it's the
difference but this Hillman is a crazy
story by the way a lot of people don't
know the full story I think it might
have been there's youngest son not his
Grand there's another element to the
generational thing you're mentioning too
uh if we're talking about rulers who
conquer and then their children screwing
things up and their grandchildren
breaking everything the same is true for
the administrative state in the United
States I actually think one of the
reasons we're starting to break through
is that it's like a flipping the
American people become gluttonous and
lazy you get a you get a fourth turning
kind of scenario where the greatest
Generation goes and fights Wars their
kids are comfortable their kids become
Rebels the Millennials become whiny you
know whiny babies but the same thing is
true of the the the uh political class
and the ruling class
you have these powerful uh intelligence
individuals you have these manipulators
and they seize control through
surreptitious means I mean like
manipulating the public and wealth and
things like that have kids those kids
inherit this but have no idea how they
got there who have grandkids who have no
idea how to manage the system and that
all starts falling apart as well I I
think you nailed it I've said before and
I mean it we have a great advantage in
this country you know Mao we talk about
Mao Mao was maybe the worst human being
to ever walk the planet obviously but
Mao was also tough as Nails Mao came up
as a guerrilla fighter who actually
trained some of our marines that
actually fought in World War II because
he had to fight tooth and nail fight a
nasty war against the nationalists Mao
was tough Mal new things our commies are
soft our comments are pillow soft they
all came from Harvard and all came from
they're all driving BMWs at 16 and then
you go right from there and you're some
jerk off assistant on MSNBC and then
you're working on Congressman losers
offers and you've never had to fight for
anything that is the big Advantage we
have are people who are normal are
getting tougher and their commies are
soft but this is why I think you start
to see this shift where centrists are
now being called right Joe Rogan I mean
he's a lefty guy in a lot of respects
but he's also extremely tough I love
bringing up that video where the woman
calls him fat and he goes what he pulls
his shirt up and it's just like he's
like a rock is an MMA guy
there's a reason why he's not saying a
vote Republican because there's very
little that Joe Rogan is going to be uh
bothered by in terms of the work he has
to do or the things he has to overcome
you end up with moderate or left-leaning
liberals
who grow up in hardship work hard and
then we get when they get older I think
for like me and my friends we're being
called conservative now because we're
just liberals who believe in hard work
who are who are not so frail and scared
that we are like gotta censor everything
that that offends us we're like ah the
worst thing ever happened to me wasn't
someone insulting me it was that time I
got shot at in Chicago you know what I
mean like so your words really don't
bother me but then you have the really
really soft Millennials who feel
physical pain when someone says a
naughty word and that becomes the new
separation between left and right or a
large component of it no I think you
nailed it they're moving so far to the
left they are pushing people to the
right but we should also keep in mind
they don't worry about popularity the
way the right does it's actually a huge
failure of the right you'll see the
right do this all the time uh Roe versus
Wade is a great example don't care what
you think about abortion I know I'm a
hardcore pro-lifer more more to the
right on that issue than most people so
it doesn't matter better but the the
point of it is this they overturn Roe
versus Wade immediately some red states
started Banning abortion in their states
you saw half of the GOP politicians and
pundits out there the pundits on the
right guys this is too far this this is
gonna hurt us at the midterms uh this
isn't this isn't popular enough when
have you ever heard one of the
Communists say well I'm worried about
the popularity no they're busy Shifting
the culture their way they're busy
getting wins while we're hand ringing
are we sure what about the Suburban
women screw the Suburban women thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time